Vous y avez peut-être joué quand vous étiez enfant
c'était un alien avec une casquette rouge
son t-shirt était trop petit et son nombril dépassait,
ses oreilles étaient pointues comme celles d'un alien car c'était un alien
Messieurs, dames, un tonnerre d'applaudissements pour.... Adibou
Je sais pas si vous avez connu Adi  ou ses deux cousins:  Adibou et  Adiboud'chou mais c'était les héros d'une série
de jeux à but éducatif, t'achetez ces jeux à tes enfants pour leur apprendre les maths niveau CE2 ou le français niveau CP .
Bref c'était vraiment pour apprendre les trucs à tes enfants en les stimulant. Mon père m'avait acheté Adibou ,
Adibou c'était réservé aux 4-7 ans, Adi c'était pour les 10-14 ans et Adiboud'chou c'était pour entre 18 mois et 3 ans.
Je sais pas comment tu fais pour jouer un jeu vidéo quand tu as entre 18 mois et 3 ans mais bon ça existait.
On se régalait là-dessus franchement quand on était gamin c'était ouf.
Aujourd'hui il y a des gens dès leurs 5 ans ils jouent à Fifa.
Nous on jouait à Adibou mon pote. Ceux qu'on pas joué ne vous en faites pas je vais vous faire une visite guidée du meilleur jeu pour enfants de tous les temps
et on fait un deal quand vous aurez des enfants plus tard et ben vous les ferez jouer à ce jeu, voilà.
Tu prends Call of comme ça tu le mets dans la poubelle et tu le mets devant Adibou et tu verras ton gamin il sera trop bien.
Bon, on va créer une game. "Lorsque tu bouges la souris une petite main se déplace sur l'écran.
Si c'est un doigt pointé tu peux cliquer l'écran." OK. "Là où tu vois une une main plate
tu ne peux plus cliquer. La main peut prendre d'autres formes selon tes besoins." (...)
Ferme lààà.
Adibou s'te plaît mec mais je te kiffais à l'époque mais là je commence à détester ce que génial c'est que là c'est un jeu
pour les 4 7 ans et regardez comme ils expliquent déjà tu imagines le jeu pour les 18 mois 3 ans mec enfaite
y'a pas de jeu c'est juste des explications pendant huit heures c'est sûr bon alors là en gros ont créé son avatar
voilà les mecs étaient perchés à fond les mecs étaient vraiment perche et j'avais oublié je me souviens que des fois j'avais peur parce qu'ils
étaient trop perchés et ce que je voyais ça me faisait un peu flipper je vous promets c'est vrai mec ose me
dire qu'un enfant il a pas peur devant ça réellement
on est au top adibou ! Tu as l'air vraiment très sympathique
j'aimerais que tu me donnes ta date de naissance beh dis donc ça te regarde pas déjà !
OOOH ! mon dieux l'interface d'adibou c'est incroyable ce qui se passe
Oui ! tu peux t'amuser, découvrir et apprendre mille chose ! absolument ! Tu peux t'occuper du jardin et de ses plantations, installer des abris pour les plantations
écoutez moi bien on va faire une petite visite guidée ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va tous se retrousser nos manches et vous allez
suivre le guide
direction la maison d'adibou ! Oh la la la mec alors là pour ceux qui connaissent pas adibou vous pouvez pas savoir à quel point cet endroit
est le temple de la
satisfaction quand tu es enfant mais vraiment ce qu'on joué adibou vous vous souvenez du gâteau
c'était the activités dans adibou on s'en souvient on va aller dans la cuisine
Tu veux voir ma bite ? déjà d'un coup il est dehors ça n'a aucun sens
Quelqu'un vient voler ton gâteau
Et voilà vous venez de faire connaissance avec le méchant d'adibou ! Je sais plus comment il s'appelle d'ailleurs honte à moi. Bon bref pour faire ce putain de
gâteau c'est très simple je me souviens comme si c'était hier
oh oui ce robot mais qu'il est tellement glauque ce robot mec je me souviens il ya une manière de parler très bizarre on dirait
vraiment qu'il nous veut du mal qui veut nous faire des choses très sombre
Moi j'étais un pro pour juste faire des gâteaux au chocolats c'est à dire je m'étais que du chocolat voilà
c'est quoi ce bruitages ! Et mais mec c'est ouf comme dans les jeux pour enfants ils mettent des bruitages bizarre pour tout tu cliques n'importe où y a un bruitage chelou
"AH !" C'est dingue ! Moment de vérité est ce que mon gâteau est réussi ?
Yes il n'a pas perdu la main le lucas même quinze ans plus tard
ah oui aussi on pouvez le décorer c'est vrai notamment avec  les petits parapluie tu sais avec leqelle tu joue pendant un repas de famille plus de ces ceux avec lesquels tu joues pendant un repas de
famille puisque tu t'emmerdes et qui casse au bout de deux minutes parce que c'est pas du tout de la qualité !
Tu veut une photo !?
vraiment je pense que tu vas finir en prison un jour c'est de toute évidence ! Aller on envoie le gâteau sur la fenêtre
Oh c'est un  gentil personnage qui le mange donc le gâteau est bon normalement non ? je crois que c'est ça
Mec ! Les bruitages c'est trop drôle
Il mette des bruitage partout tout le temps !
Ensuite tu pouvais mélanger différents ingrédients qui vont pas ensemble mais je crois que c'est le méchant qui venaient manger le
gâteau et qui l'aimais pas du tout voyons voir ce que ça donne
Yes ! C'est un bon  gros gâteau dégueulasse. Je connais bien je faisais que des comme ça
Ok donc si vous aviez des doutes quand tu mélanges du sucré et du salé
ça fait des flammes voilà. C'est quoi  ça ? Adibou : voici les recettes que tu peux réaliser chez toi si tu veut
à mes c'est des vrais recette à faire dans la vraie vie à faire dans la vrais vie avec tes parents c'est trop bien !
J'ai rater mon enfance !
Bon ! L'atelier gâteau était un ...  et maintenant petit cordon bleu qu'est ce qu'on fait ?
tu vas juste arrêter de me couper la parole pour commencer espèce de petit ont encu** d'alien ! Oh oui mec le dessins !
Adibou : Ici tu peut composer un dessin. Squeezie : Ouais Adibou : Si tu veut en savoir plus clique le point d'interrogation
d'interrogations non non non on va pas de chance d'un monologue de 20 minutes j'ai pas envie du tout adibou !
Vous voyez cette activité là par exemple c'est celle que j'ai pas asser faite étant plsu jeune vu mon niveau en dessin !  Je crois que c'est juste pas une
paint enfaite !
Oui c'est paint 100% paint voilà donc c'est un mec avec un animal mort sur la tête hein je pourrais faire une vidéo juste sur
le truc paint de adibou mec !
Yes je viens de faire un dessin de vous devant cette vidéo
Osée me dire que c'est pas vrai
tu peux l'enregistrer sur une disquette mon pote c'est fou !
Sa date tellement ! à temps je vais l'envoyer à adibou du coup je vais faire un cadeau il va kiffer alors mec maintenant tu vas juste à l'ouvrir
mon putain de cadeaux qui est dans ta boîte aux lettres pour me faire plaisir se plaît
Tout est si lent ! Alors attention attention est-ce que adibou à aimé mon dessin ?! moment de vérité
Il est génial ce plan !  Adibou : Chouette ! Une lettre de toi elle est vraiment très jolie
Mais adibou c'est pas une lettre c'est un dessin enfaite ! Il vient de faire une réponse par défaut on est d'accord il vient de
dire qu'il aimait ma lettre
alors que c'est un dessin c'est pas du tout une lettre ! Mec on est de retour dans la maison d'adibou je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez de cette télé mec mais ce qu'ont joué adibou c'est sacré pourquoi ? Voix : Merci d'avoir choisi la télé adibou la télé
clip qui bouge qui bouge qui bouge
sa date bel et bien de 2000 oui vraiment c'est là dedans que tu pouvais retrouver des
comptines mec dont la comptine la plus célèbre de ma génération
Tous ensemble ! Tous ensemble ce qu'ont joué a adibou !
nostalgie
1 2 3 trois petits chats !
Trois vilains petit petit pains ! Merde
Squeezie fais du bix box (Sur adibou alors que c'est censé être une comptine)
Tain Mais si squeezie 2001 voyez ça il serez trop ému quoi ! Ca me touche
A la la mec trois petits chats quoi !  trois petits chats !
A il y avait aussi le poste de radio qu'est-ce qui fait poste de radio ?! Radio : de place à la rigolade à la rigol'Adibou bien sûr
une petite fille arrive en courant dans le salon "Maman Maman l'armoire de ma chambre est tombée !"
Oh Vite va prévenir ton père ! Mais maman papa et déjà au courant il est en dessous !
Un garçon demande... mais stop stop mec attend tu veut qu'on meurt là arrête ! Il veut nous enchaîner des blague de merde attend ! mec
je crois vraiment que ce que je suis devenu en termes de blagues aujourd'hui je le dois entièrement à ce poste de radio ce talent
pour faire les pires blague qui soit c'est lui qui m'a tout appris ! Oh oui  le premier jeu du coup auquel j'ai joué
c'était ce jeu qui est dedans adibou  voilà on est sur un jeu seption  putain les mecs j'ai joué tellement à ce jeu je
m'en souviens très bien d'ailleurs c'était trop facile je me  quand je me disais que c'était trop simple et vraiment le truc va a 2
a l'heure quoi !
J'étais loin de me douter que j'allais être pourri à tous les jeux auxquels j'allais jouer plus tard
le triangle non ! On veut arrêter on veut arrêter !
vraiment et dit moi arrête y avait quoi d'autre dans sa maison il ya ça mais ça c'est un peu nul faut juste customiser un masque on
s'en fout un peu on va pas se mentir
oh putain ils m'empêchent de revenir en arrière je vais le tuer cette alien
Adibou : A tu remarquer le vase bleu sur l'étagère ?
Ouais
Adibou : Ca te donne une idée ?
Non pas spécialement non ?
Bah moque toi de moi je te dirai rien ah oui les graines on pouvait faire des putains de
plantation et sa poussée jamais c'était génial ça il faut les plantes et une par une ces vraiment long c'est un enfaire on va pas se
mentir
ça pousse vraiment pas définitivement pas oh mec ça pousse au fallait juste attendre super longtemps et comme j'étais pas patient bah j'ai voilà !
Je viens de réaliser un rêve putain ma première fleur d'adibou  quinze ans après
Oh ma 2 ème oh ma 3 ème oh OH OH
Abonnez-vous bon bah nickel mec  voilà j'ai réussi à faire avait poussé des putains de plantes
au putain putain non les gars non les gars ! On déconne plus là non non !
Va-ys adibou défonce le là ! Croche le va-ys croche le !
YES !
Yes j'ai toujours cru en toi adibou ! Yes Adibou : tu des visiter la maison mec ça fais 6 fois que ça fait six fois qu'on y va pour que tu me dis ça !
J'avais pas réussi à faire ça en 2001 cette vidéo  fini si bien
Les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur adibou j'espère quelle vous a plu sur ce cas n'hésitez pas à l'aimer comme d'habitude
si sa vous a rappelé des souvenirs et bien ma mission est réussie et si ça vous a fait découvrir un jeu éducatif de l'époque ben ma mission
est réussie aussi à l'époque les jeux vidéo ça commençait vraiment à exploser donc je pense que c'était bien adapté de faire un jeu vidéo
pour enfants c'est vrai qu'on n'a plus trop maintenant des jeux éducatifs j'ai l'impressions ça a été remplaçer par des jouet éducatif
t'ais dans les rayons à jouéclub toys'r'us t'sais c'est des jouets qu'ils apprennent je sais pas les couleurs ou des lettre qui sont vraiment bien foutu
parce qu'il arrive vraiment à choper l'attention de l'enfant quoi ah oui et c'est aussi été remplacés par des jeux  mobile en fait il
ya plein de gamins ou le leu les darons prêtent leur
iphone ou l'ipad et ils jouent à des jeux là dessus mais je c'est pas si c'est des jeux des jeux comme adibou adibou c'été  vraiment
pour les enfants il y avait un univers trop cool avec plusieurs personnes tu apprenez plein de chose,fin après c'est  la nostalgie qui parle putain !
putain je fais plein de bisous à très vite sur a di  adibou et adibout'chou  et on finit sur une anecdote saviez-vous
que a di veut dire accompagnement didacticiel intelligent ça fait un peu moins rêver *rire allaient à bientôt !
Abonne-toi à squeezie ! ;)